welcome back to this episode of
the stronger by science fireside chat
podcast i am your host greg knuckles
joined uh as as usual with uh
my temporary guest co-host eric trexler
eric how are you doing
i'm doing well how are you i am doing
well
um so you know we haven't done that many
fireside chats we haven't done one in a
while
uh just as kind of a recap of what we're
doing here for
new listeners people who haven't
listened to a fireside chat podcast
uh this is not a fitness podcast
we are two people who work in the
fitness industry
talking about random stuff so you send
us your questions
we share our hot takes about things
wildly outside our realms of expertise
uh try to keep it fun try to keep it
light and uh
and yeah that's what we're doing so um
let's let's launch right into it with a
question
that is kind of in our wheelhouse so
it's not directly fitness related but we
you know we read a lot of exercise
science literature
interpret it that's one of the main
things we do for our jobs and there was
a question
about what bothers us the most when we
come across it in a study so
we pull up a paper something jumps off
the page at us and just
very much grinds our gears so do you
want to do you wanna lead this one off
drex what uh
what things get under your skin yeah i'd
be happy to lead off here
um so you know i'm pretty statistically
oriented that's just like the uh
the thing in grad school i really
latched on to was really looking at
methods and statistics
um and so my my answer is obviously
biased in that direction but two things
that really
really get under my skin one is when
there are a lot of
irrelevant or unwarranted post hoc tests
and so basically um very
you know broad oversimplification here
you do your main test you find some
interesting effect and in many cases in
the models used in our field
you then have to do some follow-up
comparisons or tests to try to really
get to the root of that
interesting effect and more times than i
would
like to believe possible i'll look at a
paper and the initial analysis
makes sense they use the right model
more or less
and there's a very interesting effect
and i'm like oh let's dive in and follow
up on this and figure out what's causing
this interesting interaction
and the the follow-up testing just
does not get to the root of it
whatsoever and and so it it kind of
makes you
question if they really interpreted what
that
interesting interaction was telling them
like what the actual
theoretical meaning of it was other than
just like ah
looks like a low p value so now i'm just
going to kind of recklessly dive into
this data
so that's that's the one thing that gets
under my skin well so we we've talked
about this before
one of the potential reasons for that
right is that
a lot of people in our field use spss to
run their stats
and a lot of those more appropriate
post-hoc tests
aren't possible in spss unless you're
going to write the code yourself which
most exercise scientists don't do right
yeah so so
there's a lot of point and click options
but like
spss um the ss
part stands for social sciences like
this this was not made for uh
exercise scientists or people who are
doing you know randomized controlled
trials with
longitudinal measurements uh you you
know you could use it for that but it's
not like the bread and butter
and yeah the easily available point and
click
options don't really lead you to the
post hocs that would be
or the follow-up tests that would be
most interesting and most relevant to
the type of designs we typically see
and so for that reason people have to go
off script a little bit
i i do get the sense that a lot of
people in the field aren't very
comfortable writing their own code
so like in spss to be fair you can
totally just write your own code
and make those things happen but i think
that's a
it's a barrier or a hurdle that a lot of
people don't like to circumvent in the
field like
that is a big leap when you start going
from i point and click my options to
okay i'm gonna get under the hood and
start writing code yeah i mean i i
wasn't trying to call anyone out like
yeah yeah
i don't i don't know any programming
languages for stat software i use
jasp for that reason like it's it's
another point-and-click option
yeah yeah so so that is uh you're
totally correct that i i think that is a
big contributor is that a lot of the
really user-friendly software
applications don't make it easy to find
those really appropriate options and uh
for that reason you start to see a lot
of comparisons that either aren't
relevant to the initial thing that
they're
attempting to follow up on or they're
just really
crudely kind of slapped together
and obviously that is very prone to
having some limitations in terms of
how well you can slap that together so
yeah that that is definitely a
contributing factor
so the post talks a lot of times you'll
see the initial analysis you go oh this
is going to be really informative and
then you you keep reading on and you're
like
man there's there's a lot missing here
yeah
another thing that drives me nuts this
is more related to meta analysis
and uh yeah so
in many cases you will see someone do
something in a meta-analysis that
everyone knows you're supposed to do and
so like for instance they'll be like hey
i am going to present you with a funnel
plot
and you go great and you look at it and
it is like
horrifically asymmetrical like there are
big
problems here that need some very
serious interpretation
and they just don't so they're like
[Laughter]
they're like i understand that you
expect me to give you a funnel plot
yeah and then you do and the funnel plot
is telling me a lot of stuff
and they never bring it up again never
address the fact that there's horrific
asymmetry
and the reason it matters you know if
there's anybody listening that
that reads mass is the last two times
i've seen
a horrifically asymmetrical funnel plot
that was just totally ignored in the
interpretation
i go back into the data and i'm like oh
your effect size is wrong
that's why it was horrifically skewed
and asymmetrical which is like
dude like use this screening tool and
actually follow up
and figure out what happened here the
other time it was like
there were really important effects
in the data that were not modeled into
the analysis
and so like that asymmetry was not
rampant publication bias
it was a totally unmodeled effect in the
data
and the thing that's frustrating is that
you can you can kind of tell that
they're
they're giving you what they have been
told they're supposed to do
but they're not looking at it and
thinking what does this actually mean
you know they're just checking off the
box to say yes
i did it are you happy now and the thing
that that's crazy is like
the reason you're supposed to do it is
because it gives critical
information that needs to be considered
when you start interpreting
the actual conclusions and so to see all
the information there and it just get
completely ignored it's just like
come on this is really bad yeah yeah so
those are my two
uh what do you got yeah so
for like the five listeners who are
still here uh we
we really picked a banger to lead this
one off um
so there i i have several one is is
poor presentation of data or really like
insufficient presentation of data um
so on like the poor presentation of data
front one thing that's
that's very common in our field is um
to just use like like bar graphs to
demonstrate
like changes or kind of like pre-post
measures
um well i guess histograms
uh but yeah like that's that's pretty
common
like bar plots and and histograms when
at least for me personally i want to see
the individual
participant responses um so they're like
they're like
various types of line charts you can use
or just like scatter plots
um and that that's kind of like a
personal preference type
thing but when when you're basically
collapsing
say 20 subjects worth of data to just
like one bar
and a standard deviation like bar coming
up off of it
uh i i think you miss a lot of the
nuance
um and i totally get why you would try
to
collapse a lot of those individual data
points into
like individual lines and bars if you're
dealing with
a large clinical trial that has like 400
subjects because
you know you're not going to be able to
pick out individual data points there
but for you know for for most of the
work in our field that has
25 subjects per group if you're lucky
like you can show the individual data
you can relay more information in your
charts
um and just help people get a better
feel for your data set
um so i would say that that's kind of
like on the poor presentation of data
but then on the
insufficient presentation of data
there's a lot of
there's a lot of stuff that would be
easy to include
in studies that would help provide more
information to the reader
that most people just simply don't do
and so
a good example of this would be um
two things so one would be if you're
you're getting p
values and you just report like that it
is under the significance threshold
so you know they'll report like this was
significant p less than 0.05
which tells you something but not that
much
so for example if a p-value is like
0.048
or 0.0003
like you interpret those very very
differently because
if something is is just below the
significance threshold
it very easily could have resulted by
chance
um whereas if there's a
much much lower p value that is probably
a more
robust and reliable finding so just like
reporting that it's under that threshold
doesn't really tell you much
but then the thing that i see all the
time that just drives me crazy
is when when a study reports like
mean changes but not any measure of
variation around it
so you know almost universally if you're
say reporting things pre and post there
will be like a standard deviation or a
confidence interval around that number
so
you know people pre-training squat 100
plus or minus 10 kilos like that's
that's pretty typically how it would be
presented but then
if it's like a training intervention and
you see that they
increased their squat by 15 kilos on
average it is
very rare to see a confidence interval
or a standard deviation on that change
of 15.
and i think that that's unfortunate for
a couple reasons
one is well
really just one main reason the the
biggest thing is like
you and you would interpret it different
ways based on
how big that standard deviation is so if
you see that an intervention
improves squat strength by like 15 plus
or minus 5 kilos
that tells you that for most people
their squats going up somewhere between
5 and 25 kilos like it's it's pretty
good for most people
um and it's it's reasonably
homogeneous like you hear 5 to 25 kilos
that sounds like a big range that's
fairly homogeneous for the literature
if it was you know 15 plus or minus 10
kilos now it's completely different
like now you're probably dealing with
some subjects who actually got weaker
and some who had
you know ludicrously large increases uh
and then it
and then it can kind of get the wheels
turning like okay like maybe this is
an intervention that's useful on average
but
maybe there are some characteristics
that would tend to make it more
beneficial for some people and really
not appropriate for others
um so i can't give much
deep like many details on this but i'm
currently working on a data project
looking at some literature
um there's like around 80 studies that i
was looking at total
and i think overall 12 of
them or 13 of them something like that
reported like a standard deviation or a
confidence interval
around mean changes um
and that that's one of those things that
like that is going to be in the output
of any statistical software you use
and it takes like [ __ ] nine
additional characters in your text
to report that um so yeah like that
that's something that would be easy to
add that most people just don't
um so that that grinds my gears a little
bit um
this is one that's actually somewhat
timely for for trex and i
uh when a study has hypotheses that
don't actually relate
to the tests they run or the study that
they design
so and this is like a philosophy of
science qualm
like the scientific method what you do
is is you have an idea
you form a hypothesis to test that idea
you design a study to test that
hypothesis
and you use appropriate statistics to
make sure that you're analyzing the data
appropriately to test the hypothesis to
check your idea like that's that's the
basic process
and so like the whole thing starts with
an appropriate hypothesis
and dude there there are a lot of papers
in our field that just have hypotheses
that are
completely inane and not at all related
to
the way a study was actually designed so
uh
i i don't even remember the exact
example what was it in the
in the study that you recently looked at
well it was just so
keeping it vague so as to not call
anyone out individually the the general
idea was that
it was an intervention comparing two
diets and you know
the the hypotheses that were given
completely they had no regard for the
fact that there was a control or like a
comparison
a comparator diet in the mix it was just
like we think
this diet is going to cause this effect
in terms of you know fat loss muscle
gain
and the the problem with that is like
well you don't need a comparator group
if that's really your hypothesis and
more importantly your hypothesis
tests aren't testing that hypothesis
right yeah so yeah just there's just no
congruence
at the basic kind of theoretical level
yeah
yeah so like the whole point of the
study was
we want to see if different responses
occur in these two groups
but the hypothesis was like we think
something is going to happen in one
group
right and so yeah it's
i'm not saying that they didn't put any
thought into that study before they ran
it
but based on the wording of the
hypothesis
it certainly appears that they're like
that they designed the study
before they actually like put thought
into what their hypothesis was going to
be
right or just like didn't verbalize
their hypothesis
with their statistical concepts in mind
yeah yeah which like that's that's
science 101
like if someone has taken like a
freshman
here's how you do science class like
they should know that
yeah um i i feel like this
this is mostly like stat stuff that
pisses us off but it is
yeah whatever um so the next one for me
is like well like what else is it gonna
be it's not being like uh
people don't give protein enough love
yeah they do like it's all gonna be stat
stuff here
yeah whatever like for our five
listeners who are still here we
appreciate you
uh the next one is probably like just
laughably stupid power calculations
so let me let me pull the curtain back
here's how power calculations actually
work in exercise science
you want to run a study you have a
hypothesis you design the study
and you look and see like based on how
many lab workers we have and based on
what our budget is for this study
we can do this with 20 people like we
can put 20 people through this protocol
that's what's going to be like doable
and feasible for us
and then you pull up g power and you're
like
what would my effect size have to be
for me to have appropriate power with 20
subjects
and they just [ __ ] back calculate it
and that's
that's not how power calculations are
supposed to work and if you know
what effect sizes are and what power
calculations are like
most of the time power calculations in
the whole field are just absolutely
hilarious
um so so one of the ones that
immediately comes to mind
was uh it was it was a study
without a training intervention where
they were just giving people
leucine at meals i'm pretty sure um
so like one group was getting like three
grams of leucine with every meal and one
group was getting
a placebo supplement with every meal and
they wanted to see if that would affect
uh like fat mass and lean mass accretion
with with literally just leucine
supplementation
and so you know if you know anything
about that literature like
yeah leucine supplementation maybe it
does something
maybe it doesn't really do anything if
it has an effect it's probably a pretty
small effect
um so if you wanted to be you know if
you wanted to say that it
it has a non-trivial effect and that's
about all you can say you would say like
ah
the effect size we're looking for is a
cohen's d of 0.2 or like just over 0.2
that's probably still kind of generous
based on the leucine literature but
whatever you could possibly justify a a
slightly above trivial effect size
uh or you know if you wanted to be
be very lenient you could say maybe this
will have a medium-sized effect which is
typically
defined as like a cohen's d 0.5 um
they said that it was going to have a
large well they didn't verbalize that it
was going to have a large effect they
were like
to detect an effect size of cohen's d of
0.8
we would need 12 subjects per group and
it's like
dude if you know [ __ ] anything about
leucine
you don't you don't expect a large
effect size
and so like just to just to put some
some actual numbers on that
a cohen's d 0.8 means that you expect
the subjects to change on average by 0.8
standard deviations
which would basically mean going from
average to savage
yeah uh well average to somewhere in the
neighborhood of like the 70th percentile
for some characteristic so you know if
they started with
like i don't know like 60
plus or minus 5 kilos of lean mass give
or take like that's
that's a kind of normal lean mass number
for people in the general population
that would mean that you were expecting
them to put on four kilos of lean mass
just from leucine supplementation in
like six weeks
which is [ __ ] ludicrous like there's
no
there's no way that they actually
thought that that was going to happen
but it's it's because that's how
power calculations work in our field you
say like what number of subjects can we
actually do
uh like you were talking about with the
meta-analyses like
just having a funnel plot to check to
check a box like
journals expect to see power
calculations but they don't actually
expect to see like
good power calculations yeah because
like
to to actually have adequate power for
that leucine study they probably would
have needed like 50 plus subjects per
group
uh actually probably even more to detect
a effect size of like point two but
whatever like
they knew they wanted to do this study
with leucine they knew they could
recruit about 20 subjects and they were
like oh
let's just plug these numbers in g power
and make it work and that's
i think that's how power calculations
are typically done
uh but it always grinds my gears uh next
one
another stats thing uh so most
if you're if you're doing like a
longitudinal training study or diet
study
and you're looking to see if different
changes occur in
two or more different groups pre to post
typically you're gonna run an anova
and if you wanna see if different
changes occurred between groups
you would look for a group by time
interaction effect
and then you do post hoc tests to figure
out like
in which groups were these changes
different
but something that that used to be more
common is getting less common but i
still
see it in you know a couple studies
every couple of months
is they will have a significant
they'll have a significant effect for
time and in post hoc testing they will
see
that in one group there was a
statistically significant change pre to
post
but there wasn't a statistically
significant change pre to post in the
other group
and they therefore treat that as a
significant difference between groups uh
and sometimes well i mean
sometimes they don't even look for an
interaction effect um
which which is concerning um
but then a lot of times like you know
like maybe it was just
underpowered and like maybe there is
kind of something there but
the interaction effect wasn't quite
significant and they're misinterpreting
their statistical tests but
you know maybe it can kind of slide but
then sometimes it is just completely
egregious
where you know maybe one group puts like
seven plus or minus four kilos on their
bench and the other group puts like five
plus or minus eight kilos on their bench
and like the actual difference is two
kilos but one had
like a pre to post change with a with a
p
value of like 0.04 and the other one was
0.07
but it's basically the same change in
both groups but one of them
cleared that hurdle for significance and
the other one didn't and they're like
well
one was significant the other wasn't big
difference between groups let's uh
let's run with this and uh a little
piece of my soul dies
every time i see that yeah well it goes
back to that idea
of treating like like p values you kind
of touched on this earlier but treating
a continuous number as if it's
categorical it's either
less than this or it's not it reminds me
that that coffee study
we talked about a million years ago
where they were like well people who
drink a lot of coffee it seems to be
fine and it's like well
what's a what they're like you know
three or 25 cups a day
and you're like yeah wait a minute
you're not gonna distinguish between
4 and 24 in any way whatsoever cause
like
seems kind of like a difference you know
but but yeah it's the same kind of deal
uh yeah so that's that's that's another
thing that just absolutely drives me
crazy
um i i had a couple more written down
but there are more like
slight annoyances and like things that
really grind my gears
and i feel like we've been talking about
this long enough so let's uh let's move
onward
yeah let's do it um actually this uh
this question is about moving onward
it is theoretically uh the question was
what are
what other careers we have considered
what we might do in the future
or or what we would do differently if we
had the opportunity
to go back in time and try it all again
so i'll probably go first
you you've been talking for a while yeah
go for it uh one thing i will note this
was actually
our most asked question um
people just want us to stop
yeah you can interpret that as people
care about us and they want to know our
dreams goals and aspirations
or they're like dude just just look at
your career options there's got to be
something better for you out there
can you do anything else yeah yeah um
you know i really think i'll probably
try to get an academic job
like way in the future you know not
anytime soon but like
realistically if i'm being honest about
who i
am i cannot retire i'll die
i mean i have a very restless mind and
i i love working and i work all the time
and uh the rare times when i really stop
working for like a few days i go crazy
so that's just completely off the table
and honestly i think i think working in
an academic job like as a professor
somewhere
is a really really nice situation as you
get older
even just like practically speaking like
good benefits
as you get older you're likely to
encounter more health problems
but even just like being in a college
town around
art and culture and young people like i
think that's a really healthy way to
grow
old like in terms of like what kind of
environment you wish to put yourself in
um socially and intellectually
so i have like really thought about this
like i i
really like what i do now and don't plan
to change anytime soon but i have
thought like
when i'm 60 what am i doing
i i really do wonder if i'll end up
eventually
getting a position like that just
because it would be a lot of fun and
like
like i said a good way to to grow old i
think so
how do you see that working logistically
because i mean the the route into
academia is usually
you know be hyper productive in grad
school maybe get a postdoc position
be hyper productive there uh then become
junior faculty and
publish like a madman to to work your
way up the ladder
do you think that they would uh that
they'd spring for someone who was
60 and had never had any sort of
academic job before
and probably wasn't motivated to churn
out 15 pubs a year
i mean well they're also looking for
professional athletes and i've got that
twice over and no i mean well there's
different
academic environments you know what i
mean like it would be
almost certainly at a school that
prioritizes teaching more than research
um because i mean teaching's fun too and
like you could still
you know do a little bit of research
output but no i mean i'm not gonna like
turn 60 and be like i really need a
change of pace and then be like
you know what i'm gonna do start a
research lab at a highly funded
institution and like you know like
no no i mean that makes sense like we we
met and spent most of our time together
at unc
so like when i picture eric trexler in
academia
i picture eric trexler at an r1 uh but
no but no that that makes that makes a
lot of sense yeah i'd be very different
um what about you yeah so i
actually briefly flirted with a couple
other careers
um so if
um if if my wife wasn't as competent and
successful
i would probably be coaching people in
person so
after graduation i had a job lined up
to coach people at a gym in north
carolina
she got a very very prestigious
journalism internship
that placed her in california uh we were
already married at that point um
and we were like in the second year of
our marriage so
that doesn't seem like an opportune time
to kind of try out a distance
relationship again
um and so uh yeah i mean her
opportunity was awesome and super
exciting and so we went to california
um if she wouldn't have gotten that
internship
uh probably would have gone coached at
that gym um
talking to the owner he he kind of had
like
a vision for me to like coach for a
couple years and then
um kind of become like maybe general
manager of the gym
and uh yeah i mean that's that's
probably the track that i would have
gotten on
um and it it was basically pure chance
that i wound up on
on the road i am now um another thing
that i briefly flirted with was being a
history professor
um so i've mentioned this on on the
podcast a few times i
originally went to college as a history
major i got to like the senior
seminar like capstone class we were
talking about career options
that's what made me realize like i had
done no long-term planning i didn't
actually want any of the jobs that i
could get with that degree
yeah i was just a history major because
i liked learning about history um
but there for about two weeks i was like
you know
history grad school sounds very grueling
but i do think it would be kind of fun
to be a history professor like
once i got to the other side of that
process
um so i i was like briefly flirting with
that idea
until i don't know
i'm like i'm like vaguely misanthropic
and especially so for
people under maybe like
23 24 and so
i don't know i just don't want to work
with college kids all the time like
the most most of like the actual job
description other than teaching college
kids sounded fun but
most of the job is teaching college kids
um
and so i decided against that but i did
i did briefly flirt with it
um in terms of what we'd like to do in
the future
i have a few ideas one is uh
just buy attractive land in the country
and and do like
subsistence farming but do it with
do it with like a nest egg so that when
i like get old and have health problems
they want to be like well
can't work the farm guess i'll starve uh
where
you know basically i would be able to
have an exit strategy but
uh like i grew up in the country grew up
helping out on farms when i was young
um i like that that sort of lifestyle
agrees with me
so that is an idea uh kind of rolling
around in my mind
another one very very different
is uh you know when i decide i'm done
with
with this whole fitness thing uh and
again like many years in the future
maybe again when i'm like in my 60s or
something
like open a food truck because i love
cooking i've told you to do that
yeah like i i'm not gonna do that
anytime soon cause that would
be a lot of work and be very time
consuming um
but yeah like opening up up a food truck
might be fun
i pronounce that weird food truck might
be fun or
um just like getting a bed and breakfast
and you know like doing a little
housework through the day cooking stuff
in the morning like if they also want me
to cook them dinner like that would be
super fun um but but like something
related to food
um and then last thing
people are always surprised when i say
this but i i say this without
a shred of irony when i was in high
school
um when i was in high school i wasn't
sold
on the idea of going to college in the
first place uh i worked
lawn care and construction over the
summers
and i like legitimately enjoyed it
um you're outside like you're in the sun
like the more i'm in the sun the better
vibes i have um
i like lawn care is fun because
you get insane instant gratification
because
most things you do like you're working
along and you don't really
get the feeling of like having
accomplished something until it's done
or until you've gotten like a lot of it
done i love mowing grass because
you mow the grass you look behind you
there's no grass anymore
or like it is shorter than it once was
uh
and i just i just find mowing grass like
very zen
i i enjoy it a lot uh and then
construction like
i it's it's not something i would want
to do
when i was old um like i i very much
think that that would be
be a problem um but like as a job for a
young man like
doing that in high school dude it was
[ __ ] great
um like i was working with
some people in my family who also work
construction uh
i liked the other guys on the crew um
like it's it's a very it was like
you know it's basically doing like group
based activities outside
and working with power tools and i like
that
um so yeah there was uh
there was a while when i was like
convincing like my parents were trying
to convince me and like people around me
were trying to convince me to go to
college
um i was just like i don't know if i
want to go to college like
i really like doing lawn care and
construction and
uh you know if i would have gone that
route
i don't know that i would have regretted
it like i i think i like what i do now
more
but i don't think i would have been
upset with myself
if i went either of those directions you
know
i never like thought about doing it long
term
but when i was in high school i worked
at a gym
but i was like a kid it was like a it
was like a big like lifetime fitness
kind of branch gym and uh so i was like
a janitor
basically you know but dude i would go
to work and like you know if something
needed to be cleaned up i clean it up
but i pretty much leaned on the mop and
just
talked fitness to people during the time
of the day when they were like
super enthusiastic about fitness you
know like
everyone's coming in for their hour of
the day where they get to just you know
do their fitness thing so it was like my
life
was like living out an online
bodybuilding forum
[Laughter]
but without any negativity or like
trolling it was just like
really good times and talk and fitness
and like hey
how's that bench coming along elbow
feeling better
it was awesome like i i genuinely had
a really good time doing that and like i
never thought of it as like a long-term
deal but like
if i was still leaning on that broom
just talking fitness all day i'm sure
i'd be all right
yeah it was pretty cool hell yeah all
right
uh so i think that that does it for my
answer as well let's uh
let's move on all right all right so
next question we were asked is are we
mindful
about what we share on social media and
what is our thought process behind what
we post
yeah i'll go first i'm
i'm definitely mindful but probably not
in the way they're thinking
you know like i think when people think
of like mindfully
curating your social media it's like
i've got a strategy
and i'm trying to work towards some kind
of image or
output or something trying to mold your
personal brand
yeah yeah yeah and and that is not
uh what i'm doing
i was just on a different podcast
talking about this but like
this is just me from the heart i really
don't think
that many people need my opinion on the
topics that i see discussed
most frequently on social media so like
which
for anyone keeping score at home like
you will notice
we have not touched many
of any hot button issues in fireside
chats like
yeah like we'll we'll talk about random
[ __ ] but
we're not gonna be like okay for the
next segment
eric do you believe tara reads
allegations yeah what i mean like that's
that's just not i i have opinions i
don't
i'm very much like you i have opinions i
don't know why anyone would give a
single [ __ ] what my opinions are that's
the thing like
if i come across a conversation on
social media where i think i have a
a perspective that is important or
valuable i will chime in and i do
but what i found is that almost never
happens because like the stuff that's
getting talked about most frequently is
just not in my
area where i'm like oh they need to hear
what i'm thinking
um and and by the way i i don't begrudge
anyone who
does like to interact a lot on social
media and talk about various topics it's
just not what i like to do you know what
i mean so
i'll i'll also see like the inverse of
that where people are on social media
just to tell everyone to shut up
yeah i'm like dude chill like if people
want to chat let them chat but like
it's just not for me like i don't really
have this burning desire to
to make people address
or acknowledge or agree with my
perspective
like i have thoughts about a lot of this
stuff but i just rarely get to a point
where i'm like
you know who needs to know my thoughts
on this everybody
everybody should know so like yeah and
every now and then i will come across
something where i'm like
i really have stuff to say about this
that i think people
ought to know like i want to share this
yeah but it's almost
never using social media is almost the
almost never the right platform for it
yeah yeah you know because
if i have an idea that i think is
important or valuable
it's probably related to fitness or
research yeah and the avenues for really
clearly conveying a good
well-articulated point
typically i would lean more toward
writing an article writing a
peer-reviewed paper
or even recording something for the
podcast yeah you know but it's it's
i'm almost never like the best medium
for this is for me to write
a seven paragraph facebook status that
is like
not searchable and i'll never find it
again yeah you know
no i i agree with that wholeheartedly i
yeah i used to post on social media way
more like when i
uh like when my my
what is it even called memories like
when facebook notifies me of my memories
on a daily basis uh i have a lot of
facebook memories
from between three and seven years ago
and then very few in like the last three
years
part of that was was i just got too busy
to really
spend time on social media and part of
that was like
when when i was young and somehow
even stupider than i am now i thought
that people
would care about my opinions about
things and i thought that my
opinions were valuable and useful uh and
as i've gotten older i realized like
you know what i value my own opinions
less
uh i certainly value
so part of it was like self-reflection
like i'll be scrolling down facebook and
i'll be like
every single one of you is an idiot like
like
i don't care about any of your opinions
about anything
and i have no reason to believe that if
i posted
it would be any less stupid you know
what i mean
and so yeah i don't know i i
am less confident in my own opinions i i
value them less and uh i
i i recognize that either
other people don't value them or if they
do value them they [ __ ] shouldn't you
know
so so yeah i've shared less of them over
time
um and yeah when i post it's generally
when i post on facebook generally it's
either just like
random [ __ ] uh most of the stuff i post
is like fitness related like hey we have
a new article out check it out
um or occasionally when i
when i wade into waters that are about
something that's kind of like a hot
topic
going on in the world today it's usually
just to clarify
like random technical points that like
people may not be aware of so two
examples of that
um it seems like a lot of people like
their entire content strategy
in in these trying times are i'm gonna
post about covet 19
six times a day i'm a personal trainer i
am well positioned to share my thoughts
about this
um i don't do that i've i've posted
about it exactly twice
and both times it was like clarifying
math things
um yeah the first was like
way back in in like early or like
mid-february when people are like oh
only like
you know a couple hundred or like a
couple hundred or a couple thousand
people
in the us have it now like why are
people freaking out like so many people
get the flu every year
it was just like i don't know if you
guys understand how exponential growth
works
um like hundreds can become thousands
can become millions
like pretty [ __ ] quickly um you know
i wasn't saying like
that is what's going to happen it's just
like this is why people are concerned
like yeah try to wrap your head around
the concept of exponential growth and
like maybe that will
help you understand why people are
concerned about it uh and then the other
one
was just talking about how like
uh like linearly scaled graphs aren't
great for
looking at exponential growth so i was
like hey if you're looking at a site
that has data about this
and there's a log scaling button click
the log scaling button and then this is
how you interpret a log-scale graph
so yeah just like random technical stuff
the other one
so like i i rarely post about pot or
politics anymore
um something that i always share like
every election season
when uh when people are like this is
finally gonna be the election where a
third party breaks through
um the thing is like it kind of may but
at least in the context of u.s politics
and like a first-past-the-post
voting system um there's something
called duverger's law
and it's not it's not a law like gravity
is a law but it's something that's been
observed
in basically every political system that
has a first pass-the-post voting system
where due to people voting strategically
it always collapses to two two dominant
parties over time
um and so you know it's
it's not like that is an iron-clad law
of nature and can never change but it's
like
you know this is something to keep in
mind and and there are like
certain very like niche contexts where
like a third party can
come through so like if a if a main
party is like
completely collapsing like back when the
wigs collapsed in us history
yeah um like a third party can rise up
and take its place
or there can be like maybe like regional
parties
um that's something that happens in some
contexts
but uh but yeah so it's it's less like
telling people
don't vote third party and more like hey
if you're
if you're giving people this advice like
here's something you should be aware of
about how first-past-the-post-voting
systems
tend to function so yeah like
i'll occasionally just post stuff to
clarify technical points
um but yeah that's about it
because i when i understand a technical
subject well
i feel like my input is valuable because
i think a lot of other people may not
understand those technical
subjects uh otherwise when it's just
like how i feel about certain [ __ ]
i don't care and neither should you um
so
that's mostly like facebook because
that's like the only social medium
i think about as far as like what i post
on instagram goes
i don't know i forget instagram exists
for weeks or months at a time
and when i post something it's just to
let people who care about me know that
i'm still alive
like that's that is what's going through
my mind when i post something on
instagram like
hey still here uh
so yeah don't post it post a good
picture of oswald
yeah that's always good yeah that is
providing clear value to people
yeah you know there is one point i'd
like to clarify this came up like i
mentioned i was talking about this the
other day on a podcast and
inadvertently i think the way i was
putting it they're like you know
why do you think you're above
interacting on social media
and i i quickly was like no no no i'm
below it yeah
like i i really don't believe anyone
should care about me at all
it's certainly not my opinions yeah so
like that's the thing is i'm not like oh
look at you losers talking on social
media i'm like
they're doing fine without me and i
don't think they need me for this
yeah yeah it is it's one of those things
that can come across
pretty poorly because yeah when i say
i'm scrolling down my timeline and i
don't value any of your opinions
i don't mean that as a slight against
you or to say that like i think my
opinions are better it's like i think my
opinions are just as bad
like right yeah i don't think any of us
have worthwhile opinions
uh i i think yeah i don't know
the more i started learning about like
one
thing that i felt really knowledgeable
about the more i realized i shouldn't be
talking about anything
yeah that's except for that that's
that's precisely what happened to me as
well
yeah you're just like dude wow i've
never heard someone talk
you know explain what i'm learning now
effectively
i'm probably so bad at talking about
everything other than this
yeah that i just shouldn't do it anymore
yeah no i don't i agree wholeheartedly
all right should we move on dude
[ __ ] zuckerberg is gonna listen to
this episode and
just like not show our stuff on facebook
anymore because we're
we're discouraging the posting life that
might be true
the death of our podcast that's a bummer
all right let's
let's move on to a more
a more optimistic a more optimistic
topic
where we're going to be rays of sunshine
uh so someone asked
how do you develop self-love a positive
outlook on life
and self-confidence so let's give us the
self-love talk tracks
well so i kind of have to answer them
all at the same time
because like this really this question
really got me thinking
um because it was like how do you
develop self-love and i was like
i don't know because i hate myself
and and then i was like well okay but
how do you develop a positive outlook on
life i'm like
dude whoever asked this has never met me
because like
i comfortably skew negative for sure
like if you're in a group of people and
you're like we need someone to spot all
the problems like
i'm your guy or all the potential
problems that will never happen
yeah um but then the self-confidence one
got me because i was like you know what
like i definitely hate myself and i'm
definitely pretty negative but i
actually feel pretty confident most the
time and that really
got in my head i was like how does that
work
and i think the thing is that like i i
personally like intrinsically the
narrative that i live by
whether or not it makes any sense you
know like the narrative that guides me
is very purpose-driven and
in the things i'm currently pursuing i
have a pretty high level of
self-efficacy
so like i feel like i'm on a trajectory
that's important to me
and valuable to me um like i i think i'm
on you know on a trajectory that
involves doing some cool things
and i have a decent amount of confidence
in my ability to continue
growing and getting better at it and
moving forward effectively
and so like for me i just kind of you
know even though i'm really
negative in the immediate term my
general outlook
toward the future is quite positive
because i really do believe like yeah
just
focus on building learning growing
moving forward stay busy
keep getting better and like i do
genuinely have an
optimistic view about the future even
though i'm very
negative in the immediate term so
self-love
and positive outlook are really not my
area of expertise
by any stretch but maybe that's a
helpful revelation for someone out there
who feels similar and
by someone i mean you greg because you
said that this was pretty much how you
felt
yeah i i didn't write anything in the
outline because i was like yeah that's
uh
that pretty much covers it uh if i were
to make a sound bite about this
like i think i'm kind of a piece of [ __ ]
but i'm generally good at what i do
i uh yeah i i also have um
a relatively low self assessment
um in terms of like who i am as a person
uh and you you could well
don't because she'd get annoyed but you
could theoretically ask lindsay about
this like i get uh
i get like super depressed and
existential around my birthday every
year
because um it causes me to like
reflect upon who i am and what i've done
in the past year
and i just like never like that you know
uh
i am somewhat terrified of being alone
with my own thoughts
because i really don't like myself at
all um
but at the same time in the thing like
very much exactly what you said
in the stuff that i focus on and try to
do good at
um i think i'm pretty good at it and so
i uh
i'm i'm pretty confident
that things that i do i can be good at
them
um but that i'm just like kind of a
piece of [ __ ]
like i've said on the show before like
if i could find a way to spend less time
with myself yeah i would
yeah i would take that that i mean i
would take that trade off any day like
yeah you know the ability to just kind
of not hang out with me for a while
would be great
so like i'm with you but like i i think
the fact that i'm pretty
uh pretty like purpose driven and like i
feel like i'm
working and getting better every day
it's the same way i like
look back at the past year or two and be
like
dude you you could have been way cooler
and you know had a way more positive
impact on the people around you and you
could have been way more productive
and successful so like looking in the
rear view mirror i'm always like uh
i suck but looking into the future i'm
like okay but you know we've got
we've got enough to work with here yeah
like that's pretty much where i'm at too
like i i do have like a growth mindset
so i i believe i have the capacity to
improve
and when i look back on my life um
i think that i was like a less shitty
person
in this past year than i was two years
ago or three years ago so
you know it's it's not like it's not
like i view that
as an immutable characteristic about
myself like
i just think i suck but i used to suck a
lot more
and moving into the future i'll probably
still be a
be an utter piece of [ __ ] but like
hopefully
less and less so over time um
so i guess that's yeah i guess that's
kind of like a positive outlook on the
future
yeah and by the way we keep talking
about ourselves
you know as being just like awful people
it probably sounds like we're both like
serial killers or something
what just to put like a more specific
like frame on it one of the things that
really bothers me about myself
is uh i wish that i
was just better with social interactions
like i wish i like i said like i'm
pretty negative i wish that when people
interacted with me they walked away
thinking like
wow eric really brightened my day and i
don't think i bring that to people
at all see so i i think this is why
we're friends
because i am also
i'm like so okay if people
who know me are listening to this
they're like greg's full of [ __ ] right
now
like he he does not hate himself as much
as it sounds like
and the thing is like i have
i have an un unrealistically cheery
disposition
and that doesn't necessarily mean i'm
happy all the time that just means that
i always look really happy um
but i i do think like i just have like
good vibes through
through the day in general uh and like i
said i don't want to be left with my own
thoughts but if i'm around other people
and i'm not just like locked in my head
like i generally
do feel pretty good most of the time and
so i think like
there's something about your demeanor
that i just find very funny
and so you you are
generally like and i mean like lindsay's
the same way like you and lindsay are
both
kind of like pessimistic and like
downers but
for whatever reason i don't get
bad vibes from that like i think i think
the way that you
uh present negative possibilities is
amusing for some reason
and it's not that i don't take it
seriously like i just i just find your
demeanor amusing
well i mean i'm glad but see i'm the
opposite like you mentioned like if
you're
as long as there's like that interaction
going you're around people you're like
okay i can keep the good vibes going
the thing that frustrates me the most
about myself that that is like
i wish i was just like better is i'm the
opposite if i'm around people for a
while
i'm like come on eric bring the good
vibes but like i'm such an introvert
that i get fatigued
and i'm like telling myself eric
stop being grumpy and negative you're in
public
but i just can't i can't stop it's like
once i saturate my interaction levels i
just i can't
okay so here's what i'll say here
here's like a little bit of of therapy
for you
this is going to go far into sleep badly
so i don't remember what it was like to
not
know you like i remember the first time
we we hung out and went to beer garden
and got some beers but like
i don't remember like the details of
that interaction super well
like most of the time we've known each
other we've known each other fairly well
like we yeah
we went through a trial by fire very
early on
in our friendship um and so yeah i i
don't
i don't know how you come across to
people who don't know you that well
but exactly what you were describing
to like basically everyone who knows you
it's it's less like god eric's such a
downer and more just like
kind of an endearing thing where it's
just like there he goes again
yeah that's true and i mean like people
people know we're friends and i've i've
literally never heard anyone say like
eric's a downer to be around
i think like i think i think you're
almost so negative that people think
it's a bit
and and it's a pretty good bid
well maybe maybe yeah that's i'm gonna
i'm gonna re-emerge in like
20 years and just tell everyone it was
like a
just a complete andy kaufman you know
three decade long personality bit yeah
but no i wish i i'm still trying to get
better at that and i i think i am
getting better
intermittently you know what i mean i
don't think it's a linear trend but
intermittently i'm getting better at it
and another thing that i
you know when i say like god i suck and
i don't have a positive self-image
it's um i wish i was more present
at the moment during social interactions
yeah i really suck at that
i get so in my own head about whatever
the hell
i'm thinking about that i will
i honestly think it's why i have a bad
long-term memory
i i think i never processed most of the
stuff that was happening around me
because like i spent my whole life
literally in my own head barely taking
in the things around me
and it's just something i continue to
work on and i i have to accept
can i give you a tip for that yeah turn
your phone off put it in another room
and have like two beers
yeah but dude like you know how people
have like a bedtime routine and they're
like oh i'll like
read and it'll help me relax and like
dude
my bedtime routine for the last 15 years
has been i lay down in silence and stare
at the ceiling and
think hard and it's almost like
i need it like i need to just like i
don't know i i can't explain it but yeah
i spent a lot of time in my own brain
thinking about anything in particular
fair enough but i'm working on it
okay so here here is an actual tip
not for developing self-love that's
overrated hippie garbage
um but for like positive outlook on life
or at least like your own life and
uh developing self-confidence i think
that there's
a lot of and i mean like there's
probably people who are like
psychologists listening to this
and they're gonna tear this advice apart
like
going back to what we were saying about
social media my opinions are all
terrible
this is this is probably bad advice but
whatever
it's a fireside chat that's the whole
point of of these
um so something that i think helps
me at least is um
like being really purposeful
about trying to get better at things
and also being purposeful about
either like journaling so like actually
writing it down or just like
making a point of like intensely
mentally cataloging your process and
stuff
um so like as you develop new skills or
you improve the skills you have
it's less like you know you're getting
better but you don't feel great about it
because like you're still not as good as
you could be
um and you haven't put enough time
between like when you started trying to
improve and where you are now that you
can really look back and
and notice like oh night and day
difference
um so i think that if you're very
intentional about trying to improve at
stuff
and making making notes along the way
about like
concrete things that you are improving
at and are getting better at
then you can kind of like build up a
file of that of
you know essentially here's all this
here's all the [ __ ] i've tried
uh and here are all of the concrete ways
that i've
improved and gotten better and
hey there's there's beginning to be a
lot of them
i can feel pretty good about
you know my my ability to learn and
master new skills
and uh then i i think that
that's kind of like the key for
self-confidence
like there's there's a difference
between knowing you're good at something
and knowing that you are good at getting
good at things
if that makes sense um and and so i
think that's one of the reasons i like
cooking so much
because there's so many different
cooking skills
um and like as you know
as you practice them you just get better
over time um and so
i've learned gotten so much better at so
many different things in the kitchen
that helps me kind of like generalize it
and be like
dude i've like learned and gotten better
at like so much [ __ ]
like i'm pretty good at getting good at
stuff um
and that doesn't mean that i think that
i'm good at everything but
it's like i think that i could get
pretty good at most things if i tried um
and i think that's true of most people
um you know like there are
innate differences in aptitude and like
different realms and like there are
things that i'm good at and things that
i'm
like naturally bad at but even the stuff
i'm naturally bad at
i've i've made note of myself
improving in enough different domains
that you know i don't think i could be
like world class good at everything but
i think i think i could get to the point
that i was
like adequately good at most things that
i wanted to get good at
um and like that's kind of like the
point that i've gotten to with like
my general self-confidence so it's it's
not like self-confidence that i could
go out and do anything right now and be
great like i think i'd suck
absolute [ __ ] at most things but you
know given enough time i think i could
be
pretty decent um and so i
i personally derive a lot of
self-confidence from that um
and dear listener maybe you could too
yeah
now we've talked about a lot of stats
this episode and some
we really cracked our brains open and
did some introspective thinking out loud
about who we are to wrap it up can we do
some light-hearted
somebody asked for some outlier things
we've seen in the gym
our boy patrick umphrey yeah excellent
speaking of skills
excellent magician and just a just a
great dude
speaking of someone who is just like 24
7 good vibes
oh yeah patrick is one of the most fun
people to be around
yeah and he has one of the most fun
and just unrelentingly positive
uh presences on social media he runs a
group called
eat train progress correct yeah and if
you're on facebook you should join that
facebook group
it is it's great it's like it it's one
of the few places you can go on facebook
where interacting with people feels like
a warm hug
yeah you know it's it's awesome um but
yeah he
he was like hey so what what are some
like just outlier things you've seen in
the gym
that are just crazy and i think i might
have told the story before i'll keep it
really
brief just in case but i was working at
a i was like kind of volunteering at a
gym
with some like nutrition stuff and it
was a bunch of players getting ready for
the nfl combine
so dude comes walking out of the gym
finished his workout he's a running back
looks like i mean you name the
federation if he steps on stage he wins
just cut out of stone yeah insane
physique
he's been there training from like seven
to three in the afternoon
just getting after it and uh we're
talking to him we're like all right so
what'd you have for breakfast
he just he looks at us like like it's
the most irrelevant question you could
ask him like
that's weird like it'd be like hey
what's your girlfriend's name you know
he's like
nothing and uh just like totally
irrelevant why are you asking you know
we go okay well what what'd you have
during your session
water yeah like did you take a break and
get a snack in between no
seven to three like all day training
what do you plan to have when you get
home
i don't know i'll find something this
dude
had that physique and literally has
never
never even considered like i wonder what
i should eat sometimes yeah
it was the most ridiculous thing i've
ever seen and i guarantee if you looked
at him
you would look at him and immediately
say that dude's on gear
test him now and it's like he's like the
guy i always think of when i see people
making claims on the internet like oh
so-and-so is like
he's you know totally juiced on gear and
i'm like
dude there's i've never been more sure
of anything in my life that that guy's
natural because you can't even get him
to eat breakfast
well i mean no here's what you need to
understand he's
he's investing all of his time and
mental effort
into running the exact right compounds
and timing everything perfectly to beat
all of his drug tests
post psychotherapy on and off yeah he
just doesn't have
the mental space and energy to think
about food after that
exactly yeah i'm just like dude there's
there's no way
there's no way yeah but yeah that to me
i was just like okay
i'm never gonna accuse anyone of
anything again that's it for me
there are just genetic gods among us and
you just have to accept it
um but what about you what are some cool
outliers uh
so so one is probably
the craziest like short term
uh client like before and after strength
thing
that i've had uh and one of the craziest
that i've seen
so um not gonna name any names
because potentially personal information
but i had a female client one time
who i had previously known and had
previously trained with some
and she was already like pretty pretty
strong
um i think i think her best deadlift at
the time
like to that moment had been either like
380 or 385
um which
this was several years back like people
may be listening to this now and being
like ah there's
so many female power lifters who do that
but like
this was a while ago like that was that
was like a pretty
pretty crazy number for a female lifter
at the time um
and so she came to me and she was like
hey uh
you know trying to get back into lifting
i've
had to take some time off for various
reasons um
you know can can you help me with that
and so i was like sure like i'll write a
program for you
um her starting deadlift number was like
280
so you know she she was clearly
detrained and i was thinking like
okay over the next three or four months
if we can get you back
to somewhere in the neighborhood of like
380 on the deadlift which is where you'd
been prior
i'll be pretty happy with that because
you know she she'd been out of the gym
for like over a year at this point
um so
i was concerned early on that like
that it just wasn't going well because
she was very busy and didn't check in
very often and when she did check in it
would just be like
oh yeah doing the workout things are
going pretty well um
i think the only thing we tweaked the
whole time she was just like
hey the close grip bench is like kind of
bugging my elbow a little bit can we sub
something else in so we sub something
else in
that was like the only program tweak you
know we may be communicated like three
times and i was like well
i hope it's going well and then uh she
finished up
four months of training checked back in
and she was like oh i'm so happy like
i hit some numbers and i was like what
did you do
and she had taken her deadlift from 280
to 425
in four months um and
and that's not all it gets crazier um
the reason that she had taken time off
of lifting like we didn't talk about
this beforehand
uh and i mean i guess she just didn't
want to volunteer the information
she had had bone cancer in her femurs
um and like
i'm not an oncologist i don't know what
hey
don't put yourself down like that
i i don't know if one should expect to
gain
all of one's strength back and get even
stronger but my
my gut reaction is that like femurs are
kind of important for deadlifting and so
you know maybe there would be some sort
of like long-term
at least like slight weakness from that
i don't know um
but yeah she put like 145 pounds on her
deadlift in four months
and again a lot of that was like
recouping
strength that she had lost um but that
was still like a 45 pound pr
over her prior best yeah um
and yeah so so that was wild and
probably the wildest thing i ever heard
uh so this is
this is a secondhand story um i've told
it before
with the names included i don't think on
the podcast but
i don't know how much of this i'm like
supposed to share and yeah
anonymize it yeah so i'll i'll anonymize
it but trex can back me up he
he knows who these people correct yeah
um so someone i know was
coaching for um someone who's like
really big
in like the off-season football training
and like combine prep world
and um one of the athletes that he was
assigned to do their off-season training
for was a like rather diminutive
very very good running back in the nfl
and uh
so they were they were doing four
workouts a week
so it was like four days of conditioning
and as far as lifting goes it was two
hour body days and two lower body days
and this athlete um said like hey
like he only signed up for the
conditioning work and the lower body
training didn't sign up for the upper
body training uh and so
my buddy was like hey man like you know
i get it you're a running back
like lower body strength is more
important for what you do but like
it's not gonna hurt to get your upper
body stronger as well just so
you know you can deal with the the the
topsy-turvy world of getting tackled by
300 pound men in the nfl
and uh and this individual was like nah
man
i can't do it uh and my friend is like
no like like why not why can't you train
up her body
he's like my arms get too big and then i
i get a fumbling problem uh and
so arm is so big he cannot comfortably
cradle a football right yeah
which makes that's why i mentioned that
this was like a fairly diminutive
fellow yeah um so you know not super
long arms
and an nfl size football is pretty big
but you know
that on its face seems ridiculous like i
can't do
three months of upper body training in
the off season because then my arms will
just explode
and i can't carry a football anymore um
and so my friend was like no like that's
there's no way that's true
uh and so i forget the detail he either
got him to agree to four weeks or six
weeks of upper body training it was one
of the two
um and he he'd previously done some so
again these aren't like completely new
gains some of it is kind of like muscle
memory
um but i believe it was four weeks so
tested him on close grip bench five rep
max just to kind of get a feel for
where he was at and what loads he should
be training with uh
and his starting five rep max bench
press was like 275
which you know that's a good number for
someone who doesn't bench press but it's
not
out of this world for an nfl running
back by any means
uh so he trained him for like i said i
believe
four weeks it may have been six uh
retested
his bench number at the end that was
like the end of their uh
their agreed upon time that he was going
to subject himself to upper body
training
uh retested his bench number and if
memory serves his five rep max close
grip bench
was either 425 or 455
um he'd put a solid inch and a half on
his arms
and as soon as he finished the last rep
of close grip he racked it
he like found a football and like made a
show
of like it not being able to fit in his
arms anymore he's like see
i told you my arms get too big and uh
yeah then he didn't do any upper body
work the rest of the summer
in an attempt to trim his arms down
enough to uh
carry a football and to the best of my
knowledge
i never did any upper body work again
and so
my buddy told me this story and i
i wanted to get a feel for like how
feasible it was like you were saying
like
how could it be that someone's arms are
so big that they can't hold a football
um and so like i google image search the
guy because
i remembered him being like a pretty
brawny dude like just a little
bowling ball like busting through the
line yeah i never like noticed how big
his arms were
dude i [ __ ] google image search the
guy
his arms were [ __ ] enormous yeah he
looks like lee priest
yeah like a running back like
unbelievable and so
his arms were huge even if he was
training arms all the time but like
yeah so that that uh you just you know
any picture you've seen of him he
probably hasn't trained arms in at least
12 weeks yeah
and almost certainly longer than that
yeah um
so anyway yeah that that's a secondhand
story but i
i know the individual who told it to me
well i
i have no reason to doubt it yeah i mean
i was telling you um i used to do some
testing on some retired nfl athletes
body composition stuff and i i just
vividly remember
this one time a dude comes in and his
the sleeves on his shirt are just
screaming
you know like they're just stretched to
the last thread
like his arms are bursting out of his
shirt and i'm like
dude how often you lift him these days
and he's like uh
retired like it was years i mean like
retired x
number of years ago haven't touched a
weight since whenever i do i have to buy
new clothes
until until hearing his story or until
going through that
i would not have believed the story you
told but uh
i believe it very much yeah that's crazy
again like so i i don't want to like
name names
and sound like i'm flexing or anything
like that but uh
jim i used to coach at did have a few
like nfl athletes who would train there
in the off season
and dude
it's almost like they're an entirely
different species
yeah like i i am not someone who has
bad genes for building muscle and
getting strong but
every single one of them if they
if they like thought about powerlifting
too hard they would break every world
record
like it's it's outrageous
and that that's one of the reasons why
in in the whole like natty or not type
thing
i kind of feel like i don't care about
your opinion
unless you have worked with like extreme
outlier athletes
um just because like when you're
when you're consideration is what
what can the freakiest of the freaks do
but the freakiest of the freaks you've
ever met is like the biggest guy who
goes to your gym
you fundamentally have not experienced
how extreme physiological outliers can
be
yeah um and so yeah i mean
i feel like powerlifting is getting to
the point where some of the top guys in
the sport are like
extreme outliers i i didn't think that
was the case so much
several years back right and when i told
people like oh like all of the records
are gonna be like two three hundred
pounds above where they are now people
are like you're crazy
uh and time has proven me right
um so i do think that some of like the
upper crust in the sport now
is is getting to that like extreme
outlier range but
yeah like nfl or even like d1 college
athletes
um they are they are physiological
outliers
to a degree that you can hardly conceive
of
unless you've worked with that
population i totally agree
all right well i think that probably
does it for today's episode right
i think it does all right all right so
uh
hope you enjoyed it uh thank you for
sticking around
after our our statistical complaining
early in the episode
if you want to submit a question either
to our
our normal q a podcast which we will do
another one of at some point
if eric has me back you can submit that
or
questions for fireside chat just
completely off topic stuff
at tiny dot cc sbs qa
if you're listening to this on some
podcast platform
you know give us a five star rating if
you like it
if you don't like it please be kind
don't rate us uh or do
actually honestly like the negative
reviews are some of my favorite
but don't just leave a low star review
no comment yeah like it's gotta be a
funny review yeah so
here here's the gambit right if you love
the show
leave us a five star review if you hate
the show
do also leave a review but don't be
don't be a pansy about it like tell us
why
lay into us yeah like our
our one star reviews are are some of
like the highlights of my week
uh and we haven't gotten any good ones
in a while so so
don't don't leave like a joke one star
review like if you actually like the
show
because like if we get too many bad
reviews that does actually hurt us
yeah but yeah yeah if
you've been wanting to leave a negative
review uh you know
attach some text with it we would we
would greatly appreciate if you're going
to be negative at least be
be funny about it and very very specific
right
uh and if and if you're listening on
youtube like comment subscribe
one thing i did want to bring up so i
run a podcast called the stronger by
science podcast
not fireside chats that's my show i'm
the host
we are going to be back in two weeks so
we have been trying to get something out
every single week
we're actually going to be back in two
weeks we're getting back on our typical
schedule of every other week
and it's going to be we're going to be
putting in some more hard-hitting
scientifically rigorous content so it
takes a little bit of prep time to get
those ready
it's not just us talking about freaky
athletes we've met
all right uh so i think that does it
hope everyone
is having a good day having good vibes
and uh
we'll talk to you again soon thanks for
listening to the stronger by science
podcast
now greg and i are not experts in
medicine or health or
really anything else for that matter so
before you make any changes to your diet
and exercise habits make sure you check
with a doctor
or another health care professional if
you enjoyed this podcast and you'd like
to support it
visit strongerbyscience.com to check out
the products and services that we offer
thanks for listening and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you